meine lieben freund und mitbürger innen
entschuldigung
ein neuer kanzler dass ich das noch
erleben darf wobei eigentlich regiert
werden wir natürlich schon
vor genau einem jahr saß ich hier und
habe gesagt meine lieben mitbürgerinnen
und mitbürger innen eigentlich war ich
fest davon überzeugt dass cola im januar
vorbei ist aber
2021 genauso an wie
2020 aufgehört hat in fast
und was soll ich sagen
auch 2002 hatten sich bequem
entschuldigung unser deutsches total
versagen in der pandemie ist nur noch
mit drogen zu ertragen wisst ihr noch im
frühling große diskussion
priorisierung wer wird zuerst geimpft
wer muss warten man ging davon aus dass
sich alle impfen lassen wollen nein
freunde das hier ist deutschland das
land der dichter und querdenker auf die
würde rücksicht genommen statt auf die
vernünftigen du weißt dass du alles
falsch machst wenn die griechen um die
italiener sagen warum kriegt ihr alle
ins futter nicht auf die reihe ihr
organisierten vollidioten
als sie kurz vor weihnachten im
erzgebirge die zweitausender inzidenz
gerissen haben gab es die berühmten
erzgebirgs engel auch als impfgegner süß
es gibt wohl auch ein als intensiv
patient
war aber ausverkauft
in kleine ablenkung war der amüsante
wahlkampf der booking laschet gegen
scholz und am ende gewinnt scholz vor
genau einem jahr saß ich hier und habe
gesagt der einzige kanzlerkandidat ja
schon feststeht ist olaf scholz
im nachhinein überhaupt nicht komisch
warum hab ich so blöd gelacht
hochverdient gewonnen der ampel man
merkt er auch schon wie ein neuer geist
durchs land zieht wenige autos mehr
fahrradwege bessere luft weil es keinen
kohlestrom mehr gibt
ich mache nur spaß weil bildung von
grünen haben sie schon von der fg dreht
übern tisch ziehen lassen
ein fdp verkehrsminister
ich hatte mir gerade eine flasche
schampus aufgemacht weil an die steuer
geht die musst ich verwirrt direkt an
die wand werfen
kleiner trost im neuen ampel kabinett
gibt es keinen einzigen minister oder
ministerin aus bayern ja
wenn wir nochmal ne mauer bauen in
deutschland dann zwischen bayern und dem
rest da ist das auch gar nicht mehr so
schlimm dass christian lindner
finanzminister ist er wollte den job
unbedingt haben weil da muss er nicht
arbeiten das regelt ja alles der markt
was für ein riesiges loch der markt ist
man ja gerade an der rekord inflation
alles wird unbezahlbar
ich wollte weihnachten ganz kaufen die
war so teuer wir haben renates
nymphensittich gegessen
was ach ja
2022 ist fußball wm in katar ein land in
das ich immer schon mal nicht fahren
wollte und das mache ich auch
ich wünsche euch trotz allem ein
gesundes
2022 wir sehen uns in einem jahr wenn es
wieder heißt
2021 fängt genauso an wie
2022 aufgehört hat im fach
wenn ihr nicht wollt dass ich euch am
ersten januar um 7 uhr morgens aus
klingler abonniert den kanal
ok
dann ging ich auch aber ich brülle ein
bisschen leise